some people recognize when I convert to
Islam that there was a time I was an
atheist there was a time when I was
atheistic and the reason I am now so
absolutely certain that God is real is
because I've seen evil I've seen shaytan
assalamualaikum welcome back to the
three Muslims
here's what Andrew Ted has to say about
atheism
very well he said that the more a
society moves away from the truth the
more it hates people who speak it
absolutely and you're and you're right
and I think even the basic things I
teach because some people have said to
me Andrew all you teach about is
personal responsibility motivation
working hard getting up and doing the
right thing I said that's the absolute
those are the things they're most afraid
of if you teach people to have standards
for themselves and to be morally strong
people and to know right from wrong then
they can't brainwash you so that's what
they're most afraid of they're most
afraid of young men waking up and going
no I don't believe that you have to
believe it no I don't believe it I don't
want to and I want to go do this I want
to go to the gym and be strong or I want
to believe X or I want to be a moral
person they genuinely have a problem
with Baseline morality yes you
understand when some people recognize
when I convert to Islam that there was a
time I was an atheist there was a time
when I was atheistic and the reason I am
now so absolutely certain that God is
real is because I've seen evil I've seen
shaytan I've seen it when you see enough
evil you realize that there must be an
equal and opposite force and there are
people out there in the world today
doing the work of the devil genuine
demons who are trying to destroy the
Baseline morality that's inside of all
of us we're all born with some kind of
morality and they're trying to destroy
it and that's exactly the Islamic
understanding that we believe that
you're born with something called which
is the initial goodness you're you're
born with an innate belief receptivity
to believe in one God and then that is
corrupted in fact there's a prophet
Hadith of the Prophet where he says
[Music]
every born child is born upon this
initial goodness
and then his father and mother or his
parents they socialize him into you know
Christianity Judaism majorism so the
idea is that everyone is born with this
initial uh goodness and this initial
will or want to believe in God one God
and then as you mentioned I mean it's
what you're mentioning here is really is
profound on because you're you're
mentioning a central Doctrine in Islam
but but it's and and this is why perhaps
I found God the way I did because I
understood all these things first and
then I saw the Quran and confirmed so
many things for me you know like I've
even the conversations I've been having
so far so many things have been
confirmed and it's amazing the knowledge
that's inside of it which is so
applicable today yeah for for an old
book right you know it's supposed to be
old but it seems so so Timeless but it's
truly amazing but you're you're totally
right and and the Baseline morality I
don't think most people understand that
when they're doing this under the guise
of Tolerance when they're saying be so
tolerant that you no longer believe in
right from wrong they're not doing that
to make Society a better place they're
doing that to empty your brain so that
you have no resistance to the slave mind
programming they want to get you to a
point where if they tell you the sky is
green yeah you look at with your own
eyes yeah and you see blue but no the
sky is green that's what they want so
that you have to have nothing in your
brain that can prevent that if you have
God if you have no I believe this is
right and wrong if you have personal
responsibility if you have
self-accountability if you're a person
who sticks up for what he believes all
that's bad to them they want all of that
gone so they could tell you the sky is
green and and I don't want to say too
much because I don't want the stream to
end but they're going to tell you
something much worse than the sky is
green they're going to tell you
something else and and if they're trying
to program us all into slaves I remember
when I was in my undergraduate days and
I was reading a particular book by this
guy called Jeremy Bentham who became
like you know the spiritual forefather
of Joseph Mill who is the father of like
social liberalism of today and I
remember reading this because it was so
powerful because it linked to something
I read in the Quran he said that you
know you have two gods he said you have
the god of pain and you have the God of
Pleasure
um
that is tough that is tough I I think I
saw this clip he then goes on to quote
the Ayah in the Quran where Allah he
says have you seen the person who takes
his own desires as is God
it's powerful man it's very very
powerful they're taking pleasure as God
like the god of like reward and they're
taking uh pain as like the god of wrath
and Punishment
because that's what dictates their life
because something you you take is you
know as something you worship it's not
only things you pray to and that's you
know that's what the West has tried to
do they tried to reduce worship to
individualistic you know uh who I call
upon who I supplicate to who I you know
after I get in the war situation I
finally call on someone that's what
worship is that's when you you know you
have a God but in all ashwali
islamically a God is also somebody that
you give basically your full life to
that you worship that you allow
basically to demand you do XYZ and then
you obey them you listen to them without
any second thought as kind of a
sovereign figure in your life that's
what an illah is that's also what nilah
is that's also what God is so when you
have pain and pleasure dictating
everything you do and everything you
don't do well how is that not your God
and one example I want to give her one
kind of General way of understanding
this is
I forgot who wrote this book but someone
wrote a book and they talked about what
a person needs to live in life
and he he quoted or listed three things
he said a person needs something to do
something to love and something to look
forward to
for a Muslim it's all Allah we do
everything to please Allah and we avoid
things that displeases Allah and join
good and forbid evil
think something to love we love Allah we
love the prophet we love our families we
love our religion we love our community
we love our brothers and sisters
okay something to look forward to even
if someone like maybe in Andrew taste
position where they have so much an
abundance of materialistic things of
like they've reached like the top of the
top in terms of you know this world this
Dunya they have gentleman to look
forward to something to look forward to
in non-muslim what do they have it's all
pleasure something to do try and
pleasure myself in any way possible get
a dopamine Spike something to love
getting a dopamine Spike and feeling
pleasure something to look forward to
the next time I'm going to get a spike
in my pleasure
that's all they have and that's what
their life is
I feel like I talk so much that you guys
forget the points you had no no no
listen every every every person has
their own stream you know where one
person's gonna do a little bit more
I'm generally just still processing
everything else said bro sometimes
sometimes someone says something that's
just
it's so on point that it's like
I don't know like somebody why speak you
know like it's just like that moment
where you just gotta like relish and
just like take it in pause that was me
the whole podcast bro
yeah yeah yeah I genuinely enjoyed it
bro inshallah let us know in the
comments guys if you want us to reach
out to Andrew Tate and do a podcast
inshallah we'll try to pull some strings
and if Allah Wills inshallah will happen
all right with that being said
[Music]
foreign
[Music]